the president is set to unveil a plan
for big changes to the nation's legal
immigration system he is repeatedly
denounced the recent rush of migrants to
the southern border in today's Beach the
president will focus on people who he
believes should come to America Ben
Tracy is at the White House with details
Ben good morning good morning the
president wants a merit-based
immigration system and a senior White
House official says this is the most
detailed immigration plan ever put out
but it's what's not in this plan that
likely makes it dead on arrival on
Capitol Hill I don't think most
countries are giving us their finest on
Wednesday President Trump sounded a lot
like candidate Trump they're not sending
their best his attacks on the nation's
immigration system are the same because
so far he's been unable to change it
even when Republicans held both the
House and Senate it's a tough issue like
I said we'll see how it plays out but
it's a good faith effort on their part
now staring down re-election the White
House has a new plan but one that's
still unlikely to get through Congress
I'm not encouraged I hate to say that
the president is proposing a merit-based
immigration system that assigns
potential immigrants points based on
specific skills education income level
and if they speak English
this would largely replace the current
system in which green cards are awarded
mainly based on family connections and a
lottery the president's plan would also
increase border security including wall
construction in high-priority areas
Jared Kushner the president's son-in-law
designed the proposal and has been
trying to sell it to Republicans on
Capitol Hill
you gotta have to get Democrats in the
room it's a non-starter for most
Democrats because it does not address
the issue of undocumented immigrants
including the so-called dreamers who
came to the US as children it also does
not fix the problem of families who have
been separated I'm skeptical as to
whether he truly wants to deal with
immigration reform now meanwhile you
might have heard that the TSA is
planning to send hundreds of workers to
the u.s. southern border these are not
airport screeners these are air marshals
these are lawyers they're gonna help
with things like distributing meals and
providing legal advice John Ben Tracy at
the White House
Thank You Ben